we're back to our last session and our
first speaker is
uh jonathan belinkov and uh i know
yonotan from
times that he was a phd student at mit
and then a postdoc at harvard
and mit and he's done fantastic work on
natural language understanding um
and uh he was also affiliated with the
mind brain behavior initiative
at uh at harvard and now he
is uh starting in the technion right uh
as a faculty member
and uh he was really pivotal to this
whole research
even though he doesn't realize it but
his talk at radcliffe
on natural language processing which was
part of our
mythical by now machine learning
mythical ferocities
machine learning uh study was really
what started this question of
what are some other domains where the
methods of nlp can be used
and specifically in this animal kingdom
and in wales
thank you very much for agreeing to give
this talk and tell us a little bit about
nlp
go for it thank you thank you thanks
shaki and thanks for inviting me
thank you also david and michael for
inviting and
organizing this workshop uh before i
begin i must
also apologize to part of the panelists
and participants for missing
most of yesterday i was able to catch
part of
michael's talk as i was driving in the
car
so i i hope i got the gist of it
um but hopefully this
method from nlp would be somewhat useful
i try to
start with issues that are more closely
related to my research about
interoperability
and then i'll try to leave enough time
to
just point out a few other research
topics
uh in natural language processing that i
think could be useful to decoding
communication in non-human
species
um so i assume you see my slides but let
me know if you don't
uh so the outline for this talk is first
we'll
just present the current predominant
approach to natural language processing
which is using very large scale
language models some of it michael has
already
mentioned yesterday and i'll spend most
of the time on
ways to interpret and analyze what's
going on inside these models
especially focusing on limitations of
analysis methods uh but then the
end of the talk will be a few other
topics that i think would be relevant
first
about grammar reduction how you induce
grammars um generating languages from
raw texts
then unsupervised machine translation so
this is a scenario
where you have um two languages and
you'd like to translate between them but
you don't have any
example translations of the specific
sentences or so-called
parallel data um amazingly you can still
do something
and finally there's uh
interesting research going on on
artificial agents and what kind of
language they develop when they
are trained to accomplish some tasks
a cooperative task or competitive task
so we'll talk a little bit about that
so this is uh how usually natural
language processing works these days
um we have some kind of input and some
kind of output
and in between there's a big artificial
neural network
so this is a very large model
potentially
complicated and we train this model on
these example
input output pairs by adapting all sorts
of
weights parameters inside this model
now this is an example
if we're talking about machine
translation
the input is some sentence in the in a
language such as spanish in this case
and the output is a sentence in another
language
english in this case and again we'll
train the network on lots and lots of
examples of
inputs and outputs now
this seems um fairly reasonable to do
but historically
things work actually very differently
so up until something like five years
ago
five or six years ago machine
translation
for example used to work very
differently uh we had these very
complicated uh engine heavily engineered
systems with a lot of different parts
you don't really need to go into the
details of this
diagram um it's enough to understand
that
we used to have all sorts of components
in a very big model in a very big system
for instance if we're talking
translation we used to have
um a language model that's something
that predicts the probability of the
next word
uh we had lexicons and phrase tables
these are
sort of dictionaries we had some other
component for
reordering words because there are
different word orders in different
languages
and potentially many other features that
can each be integrated
pertaining to morphology syntax or
whatnot
now the main uh difference here
is that in this pyro approach we
used to develop each of these components
in isolation
and then combine them in in some way and
um
that worked out okay but it does mean
that
each component is tuned to a different
task and not necessarily to
the task that we really care about which
is in in this case the machine
translation task
now go back to this end-to-end learning
approach where you take an input
and output and uh plug the input into a
new network
here um the entire system is this neural
network
and it's all trained on the test so the
task is to translate
everything in this model is tuned to to
do translation
so it's a very compelling uh
or very appealing way to accomplish this
this task and it also ends up
working better uh in practice uh
so this is all good and well um
here's a minor tweak on this idea um
so recently what we found out is that
now let me go back this this this idea
still assumes that you have a lot of
examples of whatever tasks you care
about so
if we're talking about translation we
need a lot of example uh translation but
but if what if we only have a few of
those or verbal
um so here comes pre-training the idea
here is that we'll first
pre-train a model on some task and in
this case we'll
we'll design tasks that are it's very
easy to
collect data from so for example we can
take a sentence like
mary did not slap a green witch
but mascot or blank uh one of the words
and then what we'll ask is uh ask the
the neon
network to predict uh the missing board
or fill in the blank
this is a task that's uh very easy to
generate you just need a lot of
texts and occasionally you'll drop out
some words and
mask them and ask the model to fill in
the bias
um and it turns out that this this idea
leads to very good models that can be
used for them
other tasks so we'll take this neural
network and um
that was trained that was pre-trained on
this filling the blank problem
and then we'll fine-tune it which means
we continue
training it and adapting its parameters
on some other tasks so another task
would be machine translation
question answering or whatever and
usually typically this other task will
have
much fewer data points so um
we don't have as many examples but
because we've already pre-trained
the model on la tomato text
we it turns out that it has learned
pretty good
representations for language that can be
then adapted for very many different
tasks
um so this by now is uh i would say
any state-of-the-art result almost on
uh natural language father saying works
in in this way
and i've listed a few uh design
um okay so what's the problem
uh the one major issue that i'd like to
mention is that
this big model is uh pretty opaque
or often thought of as a black box so
we're not really sure what's going on in
this model um and we may want to ask
very
a few different questions about this big
neural network model
um we might want to understand something
about its internal structure
it is comprised of various
transformations linear transformations
non-linear transformations arranged in
layers
with all sorts of connectivity what's
going on inside
what's the role of different components
uh that's something that we just don't
know because
all these different components are all
remember just
trying to perform some end tasks such as
translation
um we might want to ask how it uh
behaves on
different data sets and different kinds
of data and
the natural language processing
community now is starting to realize
that
it's important to pitch these models
against
all sorts of stress tests and not just
measure their performance on some
common benchmarks but actually tease
apart their
behavior on uh carefully curated
examples um another
question is why does it predict what it
predicts so
this model is trained to take an input
and method to an output and then it
generates a prediction but
why what drives this prediction or this
decision what part of the input perhaps
influence the the decision what internal
computations
happen that make the model arrive at
such uh prediction
and also quite importantly when
can we say something about when would
this model work well or
not work well um you may have heard of
um
adversarial examples or fertility
problems it turns out that a lot of
these
neural network models are very fragile
if you change a little bit
the the input you insert some noise or
you change it in a malicious way or a
benign way
things break and then things don't work
well
so can we characterize this um these
kinds of behavior
so these are a lot of these are a few
different um
flavors of interoperability that people
in the community are interested in
uh i'm not going to go through all of
them i'd like to
focus on the first question which is
about the structure
and how we can analyze uh the
internal structure of a different
network
okay uh so in a structural analysis
uh we take this neural network
uh some function complicated function
that maps an input
to an output and we would like to look
at some
particular part of that so for example
we might look at
the output of the network at the elf
layer so it's an
intermediate step in its computation and
then we could ask
various kinds of questions we we want to
know
uh what is the role of different
components of this
neural network what's the role of the
particular layer that we
are observing um what kind of
information
is captured in in different components
uh
these networks are trained on a a lot of
wall texts um and it turns out that they
generate representations which are
useful for
many different tasks so presumably they
acquire some kind of
information about human language
that is represented in some way
internally in the mob
so we'd like to be able to answer ask
questions like
does a certain component in the model
know something about a certain property
and components are things like
layers neurons properties uh various
linguistic
features or linguistic properties um
they could be morphological patterns of
words syntactic structures of sentences
uh compositional semantics and and so on
okay so um here's uh
the predominant approach these days
it's known as a probing classifier the
idea is that we will
take this model and we'll
run it on a corpus of some inputs x
um which come with some linguistic
annotations
uh z uh so here we resort to
a whole body of work in natural language
processing and
linguistics which annotates um
various properties on on different
datasets
so we rely on supervised
learning scenarios where people have
already annotated
our data and given this uh annotated uh
these linguistic annotations we'll take
representations
uh from some part of the model and then
train the lower classifier
this uh that i defined here with g and
what this does it maps
these representations to uh the property
that we are now studying
um and then we can train this as a
supervised learning
uh scenario and evaluate to the the
accuracy or some performance measure of
this asp
and this accuracy will be considered a
proxy to the representation that
we are now examining um
so let's make this i'll skip the
information theoretic stuff but
let's make this a little more concrete
um
this is a list of some references using
this methodology
and in what aspects they studied
so f here is the neural network model
that is being studied
x is the the inputs
y is the output of the neonat
model s that is the original output
that the model was trained on and g is
the
classifier the probing classifier and
z is the linguistic property that we are
now studying and you can see that
we'll focus on the rightmost column z um
there are various linguistic properties
that have been studied in the literature
including morphological patterns
semantic walls
syntax very syntactic features uh
and so on if we then uh
move to the left and look at the column
f
uh there are also various neural network
uh models that have been studying using
this methodology
and i'll just run for them quickly if
you're not familiar that's
not not so important but people have
looked at various word embeddings
sentence embeddings these are ways to
represent words and sentences
uh mathematically as vector multi high
dimensional vectors
various kinds of deep neonates like
return neural network
um models for machine translation
uh tree based recurrent neural networks
and all the way to nowadays
largely trained models uh elmo and bird
and various sesame street
uh characters that are popular in uh in
lp these days
um okay so this is a very partial list
and by now this
idea of trying to decoding information
from a model using classifier is very
common and
there are probably dozens of uh
of papers or more using this
methodology uh so let me show you some
example
results from from our own work uh
i'll show examples from a work on
machine translation and
if you would like to look at various
other examples then
we have a survey which provides a big
table
much bigger than the one i showed you uh
and various categorizations of
this kind of kind of book okay so
how does this work in the machine
translation case uh
we'll have this model f which will be
a recurrent neural network based encoder
decoder
model and we have x and y
as the input and output in this case
they are source and target sentences
uh meaning sentences in some source
language and uh there are translations
in a target language our classifier g
will be a
nonlinear classifier in this case a
multi-layer perceptron
and i'll come back to the issue of what
is the
what kind of classifiers we want to use
a little bit later but for now will be
just this uh
and z will be various linguistic
properties of words
uh either in the source sentence x or
the
target sentence target translation y
and the first linguistic property uh
that we're
asking we're looking at is morphology or
the structure of
uh of words uh this is important for
machine translation
uh used to be solved with various
feature engineering approaches and
nowadays will just be the
neural network and seems to work well so
kind of natural to ask whether uh neural
nets acquire morphological knowledge
um in parentheses here i'll just note
that
the choice of which linguistic property
or which property in general we
we're interested in depends on our uh
familiarity with the task with the
domain that we're dealing with so if
one is studying um if if one is training
a large language model
on or a large sort of language model on
the
animal localizations then one should
have some
prior conception on what kind of
properties
would be interesting to look at
in our experiment we'll look at the
f l of x these are the representations
from
uh the neural network model at a certain
layer
l and we'll try to predict the
morphological properties
um this is a more complex morphological
tag for instance saying that
the current word is a verb past and
singular
feminine or it's a it's a noun
it's a plural noun
okay so this is a
diagram showing this procedure just to
visualize it a bit
we have three steps first we have to
train
this original model f on
example translations then we'll generate
feature representations from some
internal parts for example here we're
taking representations from the first
layer
in a in a deep model and finally we
train a separate classifier on these
representations
um to predict some property for for
example here we're predicting the part
of speech
and so we like to say that the word we
is a pronoun
and not a noun or a verb
okay so let me show some results um
so these are results from predicting
more fallout morphology and the y-axis
is
accuracy x-axis is showing various kinds
of
models in different languages language
pairs german english checking their
spanish english
and so on within each group
the different colors indicate the layers
from which we took the representations
lighter layers
lighter colors indicate layers at the
bottom so close to the input
and darker colors indicate layers at the
top so close to the output um except for
the very dark
the very dark darkest color that we can
ignore for now
but omitting this the pattern that we
see
is that the accuracy decreases with
layer depth
so lower layers are better in terms of
having morphological information in them
that we can actually
decode which is in fact uh
when we first saw this result we were
quite surprised
because the common assumption is that uh
deeper models
perform better so you need a deeper the
deeper layer
uh the deeper layers but here there's an
example where at least for the
question of morphological knowledge the
deeper layers are
not where most of it is happening so
you're not
i don't understand can you explain a
little bit so on the
on the x-axis i see that which languages
but when the y-axis which is what you
what are you trying to predict exactly
and yeah so
the y so let me go back here we're
predicting
the uh morphological information of a
word
uh based on the representation so for
for example if we have the word we
would predict the morphological
information or in this case it's
saying that we as a pronoun
english to check so what's that's how's
that playing there
sorry but you are on that on that graph
you have two languages so you have
yes um so in the right so in the
translation case we have two languages a
source language and a target language so
for example
look at the leftmost side german english
that means we start with
german sentences and translate them to
english um
all of these models kind of skipped over
that but all of these models are made of
an encoder and a recorder and then
quarter is
a part of the network that encodes the
source language into some vector
representation and the decoder
takes the spectral representation and
generates the target translation
so the encoder works on the on the
german side
in the case of german english and the
decoder works on the
um on the english side and what you see
here is that the first four
groups of what our analysis of the
encoder representation
and the last for our analysis of the
decoder representation
so we can extract those representations
from any part of the model which that we
want here we
looked at the representations either
coming from the encoder side
or from the decoder side and the
accuracy is in the mapping let's say
from verb in english to a verb in czech
i know so the accuracy i'm actually not
showing how
you how good the model is in translation
um that's that's not shown here this
accuracy is showing the accuracy of this
classifier which we call a probing
classifier
uh which is something that we that comes
after the model has been
trained on translation but we asked a
specifier how good can you predict can
you decode
certain properties so in this case this
is a classifier that tries to factor
represent a vector representation of the
word from in
from the model this thing here in the
middle
and predict the part of speech or the
morphological information of
of the word corresponding to this
representation
so this is an auxiliary way to say
um to to give us some quantitative
information of the quality of
this representation with respect to a
particular linguistic property
is that clear no yes
okay so the main the main takeaway from
here is that
we see this uh decreasing accuracy as we
as we increase the layer or as we go
deeper into
into the model and this is a a bit of a
peculiar behavior because we know that
the
deep models are good i mean that's what
the whole deep learning is about
so um natural follow-up question is
what's going on in the top layers if
they're not about
if they're not really representing
morphological knowledge really well
what do they do um so what what we found
out is that
you can vary the properties and figure
out
other aspects of language so here i'm
showing
a very similar graph in its structure
but what we're trying to predict here is
the syntactic uh patterns in in the
in the sentences in particular um if
you're familiar with this what we're
predicting here is syntactic
dependencies
or relations so given two words we would
like to say what's the relationship
between them
um relationship can be for example if a
relationship of a subject in the verb or
not a direct object or an indirect
object or
um no various other syntactic
relations but if that is not very
primitive that's fine
the main point here uh is that we're
predicting
something about the structure of the
sentence and how words combine
with one another to form larger
meaningful units
and um again the y-axis is the accuracy
in predicting these syntactic relations
and you can see the pattern is quite
different here
uh again darker colors indicate deeper
layers so if we go from left to right
in each block we see that accuracy goes
up
in other words the deeper layers are
better in terms of
having representations that contain
syntactic information
so this is a differentiation between
syntax and morphology that we've
we've found and we've also looked at
semantic
properties uh semantic relations these
are predicate argument relations to
those
familiar with them um and they seem to
behave quite similarly to
the syntax case so again deeper layers
lead to better representations in terms
of how much semantic
information they contain uh we did
so we what we see here is a separation
between
morphology on one side uh this
is better represented at lower layers
and syntax and semantics
on the other side um we've started
looking at
uh how to tease apart the difference
between syntax and semantics but
didn't do much work about that so uh
i'll skip that for now
uh so to summarize this part uh
what appears to be happening in these
deep language models is that they learn
sort of
hierarchy of of language properties
where
this hierarchy corresponds to some
notion of how language works uh you can
imagine that
uh at the bottom of the hierarchy are
simple lexings or lexical units
such as words and their parts and then
as you go deeper into the
hierarchy first you may combine parts
to form words then combine words to form
phrases and relations and full syntactic
trees
and perhaps go deeper or higher into
that
into discourse units propositions and
so on uh so this is a
sort of language parity that corresponds
to the
layers at least partially corresponds to
the layers in in the deep model
and we call that this different network
was only trained on some input output
pairs
which in our case were the translations
we did we never told the
this network how to represent
uh parts of speech morphology or syntax
we especially never said uh
we never told indicated that a certain
property should be represented
at a certain component um and
if this is a little familiar then you
may
you may recall from a computer vision
that in
in the deep neural nets that process
images
uh often uh there are also there's a
sort of
vision hierarchy uh shallow layers close
to the input
capture simple properties of images or
objects such as
edges and parts and as you go deeper
into
the network you get full objects or even
complicated
scenes um there are also
similar sort of similar signs uh
happening on the speech side and and i
think that
might be interesting to to people um
in the studying uh animal communications
but
uh a sort of speech hierarchy that we're
seeing
is where uh simple features
articulatory features happen at the
bottom and
phonemes are represented at the middle
or
higher layers of of models
okay so
so far about results that we've seen
i'd like to go into a bit about the
limitations of this approach
so a quick uh recap
the setup is that we have some deep
neural network model
f word which is then trained to map
inputs to outputs and we have
a separate classifier g which takes
those feature representations
coming from f and and learns to decode
them into
a linguistic property z and
i've lost over this but mathematically
it turns out that
what g does is it maximizes the mutual
information between
those representations f and property z
uh so here are some questions uh
i've shown you all these accuracies um
but
uh of morphology and so on but what do
they mean uh and
specifically how do we put these
accuracies in perspective what should we
compare this accuracy to
so a lot of studies focus on relative
performances which is what we've
uh we've done in our example we looked
at
um the same property the same setup and
classified and so on but we compared
representations coming from different
layers
then we could say um some layers lead to
better representations in terms of
this decoding accuracy that we give
but if we get a number such as 76
what does it mean is it good is it is it
bad um
so it's often useful to have some
external numbers to compare that to and
some common baselines that are used are
using random features it turns out that
if you
take a deep neural net which is random
meaning it was never trained it still
generates
a pretty useful feature representation
so that's a
kind of a naive baseline but it's a
pretty good baseline
um to work with and you could also
compare the deep neural net to
simpler kinds of word representations
for instance
wood embeddings that are non-contextual
we work with machine translation models
and
most people these days work with
contextual representations where the
representation of the world depends on
its context but um a useful baseline is
to compare with a non-contextual
water presentation um
so these are kind of baseline or lower
bounds we would like to verify at least
that uh our
probing accuracy is above this lower
bound
um it's also useful to look at high
lines uh
or some upper bounds so often you will
see people recording the
just the state of the authentic task so
how good can you
um do how well can you perform on
predicting
morphological information just if you if
all you care about is particularly
morphological information forget about
the original model f just train a model
to do morphological
tagging and um and this presumably will
be will do better than our probing
classifier because
it's not constrained to do anything else
but
if we compare our result to the skyline
we we know how far we are
and how perhaps how much information is
is missing from the
representation okay so that's a certain
question um
it turns out that just looking at the
accuracy is not is
not a very good um number to look at
in particular an interesting study by
people from stanford found that um
you a lot of what these models do is
memorize
what they see in the in the data and
simply memorize word types so they
designed a very clever
control task which is a task that only
the
the classifier g export and tesla ig can
learn
but the original model f cannot and
specifically what they asked
this password to do is they said well um
given all the words in that you look at
assign a random label to each word uh
word type
so ev every word will always appear with
the same label but this is a random
label
and and the customer rg can learn that
because it's it's being shown these
random labels the original model had no
notion of those
labels whatsoever so it cannot possibly
know anything about it
and the point that they're making is
that a good probe
a good g should have very
high accuracy on the real task that we
care about such as predicting morphology
but it should have low control accuracy
so it should not
be very good as just assigning random
variables because this is a meaningless
task that can be solved by just
memorizing um
and i'm not going to go into the these
results here but
it they've shown that if you look at
this measure of selectivity that they
define you get somewhat different
results from just looking at the
accuracy so accuracy is not always
the correct measure to look at
um another question that is
uh i think i mentioned a bit is
the kind of classified g that we should
use uh
what kind of classifier should we choose
and how does that affect the
relationship between
the the classifier and the original
model f
um and a common uh thing to do
that you see in the literature is to
just use a linear classifier
and the idea is that what we're trying
to do here is we're trying to analyze
our presentations um and how good the
representations coming from the original
model f
are and we're not necessarily
trying to get the best possible
classification accuracy
so we shouldn't have a very complicated
um probing classifier g
and accordingly um i could say that it
seems
not to matter too much which classifier
to use because
if if what you care about are the
relative uh
performances say which layer is better
than
usually the the identity of the
classifier doesn't matter much
but that's um not a very comprehensive
study um
okay there's some theoretical uh
work on on this question of the
probe g that i think i will
skip here um
but i would like to mention this this
new work
um from voda and title
so they had a very interesting idea
we have this classified g and it can be
a linear classifier non-linear
classifier whatever
and and we get an accuracy um but
there's a very big difference between
different classifiers and
a non-linear classifier is much more
expressive it can do a lot more
it has a lot more going for it maybe
that's why it's getting this
higher accuracy so what they
suggested is to measure not only the
quality of the
classifier but also its complexity
and to do that they use a minimum
description length
estimator which means
suppose you want to
take the property z and transmit
information about that
to someone else uh assuming that some
that someone knows
um the representation uh coming from it
um how expensive is it to transmit
information
so this is the minimum description
length and
and they show uh ways to estimate it and
end up reporting two numbers uh one is
just
accuracy or some similar measure which
is
quality of the classifier g this is how
well you can
uh predict a property from the
representation
uh and the other quantity is the
description length meaning
how hard was it to train this classifier
to to obtain this
um this predictor um
i think this is a very neat idea that
probably will will stick in the
literature they also show that
it's important to look at this idea of
the
minimal description length because you
get different insects
um for instance you you may think that
um the certain layer is very good in
predicting and that means indeed be the
case but
sometimes you'll see that this comes at
the expense of having a very complicated
uh code or a very complicated
description um
meaning that it was pretty hard to
achieve this um
this this prediction oh in other words
you could say if we look at the
representations
coming from the model f sure they may
contain
the information necessary to predict the
property z but it's
so um it's
it's encoded in such a difficult way in
such a hidden way that it's very
difficult
to extract it and you need to work a lot
when you talk about how many bits are
required so is this analytic work or
again it's
empirical um this is an empirical work
so you can't really analytically say
because it all depends on how good your
classifier is
and we have a limited sample
so we have to estimate it empirically
yeah it's a limited
knowledge scenario so i don't think we
could
uh we could give like an analytical you
know but even
about how many bits are required to
transmit z knowing f of x
it's an estimate it's it's an eyeballing
kind of thing or is it
oh no no it's not an estimate it's not
an eyeballing kind of thing it's
it's more like they show that you can
they prove that this well i don't know
if proof is worthless but they show that
you can approximate
this question by looking at the
difficulty of training the classifier
so they have they have a couple of
different ways to do that but you can
imagine if it's
if it's a it's very difficult to train a
classifier then you need more and more
of it
okay okay uh so the last question
which i think is the most exciting one
is uh
what kind of me what kind of insight we
get from this sort of
this whole sort of analysis of the
probing classifiers
um what this does is again recall we
have a
representation f and we're training a
classifier g to predict some
properties z what what we end up getting
is some sort of correlation between the
representation
coming from the model and the property z
oh in other words
this isn't telling us anything about how
the
original model f was would behave on the
task it was trained on
i recall it was trend it wasn't trained
on anything to do with the linguistic
property z it was trained on some other
input output pairs x and y for instance
translation so now when i showed you the
results on
an analyzing machine translation i said
something about morphology and syntax
and so on but it wasn't connected
to the actual translation task in any
way
and in fact some people found that um
there is either a no correlation or even
sometimes a negative correlation between
how good a probe is and how
good the model performs on the task it's
kind of
undermining a bit this in endeavor
um so an alternative direction for
analyzing these uh these models is to
perform interventions in the
representation
uh if we if we intervene on what their
presentations are
and then um see how this affects
the the predictions their behavior then
we can say something causal we can say
that
sure this representation affects the the
the
model behavior in a certain way and
i think this is a very promising way to
go
and i've listed here a few papers
including
some of our recent work uh if you're
interested in
looking more into this okay
so i think this is looks like i have a
bit more time
this is perhaps a good point to stop
before i move to some
other uh stuff if there are any
questions i can not answer one or two
i think there's one question in the chat
by juba
can you see that let's see okay i only
see the q and
a oh yeah yeah
oh yeah i see the chat
okay
so there's a question by brandon which
languages
tag are you trying to predict as
accuracy on the other languages
tag improve as the first decreases um
i think so i think this is probably
referring to the translation case
um let me go back
to that
so uh what we did here we tried to be
fair when we compare the encoder and the
decoder performances so
on the left hand side these four first
blocks
we're looking at the encoder
representations of
these non-english languages like german
to german czech spanish and french so
it's translating from german
to english or from check to english and
we're looking at the
morphological the morphology quality
on german or in english on their
four last blocks we're looking at the
decoder side but here we flip
the the order of the languages so here
this is a translation
model translating from english to german
and then we look at the decoder side
representation meaning we're again
looking at
german morphology so we actually predict
both of them
i don't have a direct answer to what
happens to
accuracy on the other language languages
tag as the first decreases
we i don't think we've looked at that
okay
so let's get back
all right so in the time remaining uh
i'd like to mention a few
other uh issues from nlp that might be
relevant to
to this workshop a couple of displays
disclaimers this is
not a representative um presentation
of any of these topics firstly
because now of time but most importantly
because i'm not an expert
on on these so there may be omissions or
misrepresentations so
take this carefully but hopefully the
enough references to be useful for some
follow-up discussions
so the first problem that i think is
interesting to consider is called gram
induction
so in grammar induction we're given a
collection of strings
and we need to infer grammar generating
those strings
uh usually in in nlp we are given a
corpus of sentences
uh such as the sentences listed here on
the left and which i would like to infer
grammar generating them for example it
might be a context free grammar
and you you might have a different kind
of
data data set and different kind of
grammar but
this is what's commonly done so you're
giving
all these sentences on the left and
you'd like to say you'd like to infer
grammar of this sort uh
that has rules rules are things like s
goes to npvp so this is the sentence
a sentence and it goes to a noun phrase
and a verb phrase
uh the noun the np goes through that np
so the noun phrase
goes to a determiner and another noun
phrase vp is
a verb phrase and it goes to a verb in
the noun phrase and so on and so forth
so
these non-terminals that are listed here
have some meanings
linguistic meaning uh of course this is
an unsupervised
problem and uh we only have those
record we only have those sentences on
the left so we don't know
any of the rules we don't even know what
are the non-terminal types so we don't
know anything about
noun phrasal verb phrase or terminal all
that stuff
so the most we could hope for is perhaps
to get something that looks like this
some some non-terminals that we
don't have any meanings to associate
with but this is the problem
uh and and this this problem has all
sorts of cognitive appeals
uh as well as perhaps some engineering
appeals but it's it's a major problem in
computational linguistics
uh it is in fact a very difficult
problem so for instance in english it
turns out that it's very difficult to
beat a very trivial
baseline that takes a a sentence and
always derives it with a right front
white branching tree so this is this uh
naive baseline works actually pretty
well
and if you have a different kind of word
order language
then you might have a another very
simple baseline like a left branching
tree um but still there are a lot of
there's a lot of work on this
uh there's work on inducing constituency
structures
uh such as uh trees derived by uh
context regrammers there's a lot of work
on dependency structures that
if you're familiar with those uh they
are
somewhat different syntactic formalism
um i've listed here some
all these are hyperlinks that uh i'm
happy to share and people can
follow up on but there's a timeline of
various uh
advances and uh recently there have been
a few advances using
deep neural networks including
latent variable models that are quite
exciting
so here is a table of recent results
from kim at all
these results are this is a
f1 measure of the quality of the
inferred
um trees that correspond to some grammar
so that doesn't matter how we compute it
but higher is better that's the the main
point and if you look at the top
you will see also the previous models um
what i'd like to highlight here is the
right branching baseline
is 39.5 you can see that after
up until 2018 it wasn't
nobody actually really beat this um this
naive baseline but recently there are
quite a few advances
where things go up to the 40s and 50s
this particular paper
goes all the way to 60 or something like
that
so it seems like from getting there uh
but it was still quite far so oracle
trees
as a sort of estimation of how good
humans would be and uh this is still
quite
there's still quite a back again um but
perhaps some of these
ideas could be useful in inferring a
grammar on a sort of a
different communication uh i think it
would require stipulating
what kind of grammar at least it should
be
i don't know if there's a lot of uh
understanding of
whether animal communications are
a regular language corresponds to
regular languages context-free languages
and so on uh okay
uh on to a different question um machine
translation
uh the usual machine translation setup
which
i've mentioned a bit is such that we
have a parallel data set of source
sentences and their target translations
then we learn a translation model this
is a supervised learning setup so we
have labels
labels are those target translations
um but this is a very strong assumption
and we don't have
all those labels for many different
language pairs and languages and so
recently some people have looked at this
question of what to do if we don't have
any parallel data
so here we are given two data sets one
in each language
and we need to learn how to transit
between the two languages so imagine
you're giving a bunch of texts
in spanish and a bunch of texts in
english but there's no correspondence
between them
and you somehow need to learn to
transfer so this is an unsupervised
learning setup
and and honestly it sounds impossible
uh it turns out that it can work somehow
uh so just in the last couple of years
there have been a
couple of recent papers on
on doing this and i think i think some
of this was mentioned also by
michael yesterday the idea is that
we take those neural networks and and
ask them to do encoding and decoding in
a particular way
specifically uh these tables used auto
encoders
so these are models that start from some
input and
encode it into some vector presentation
but then go back to the input
and you interleave those auto encoders
with
encoder decoders meaning
parts of them all that encode and a
sentence and
decode it or generate a different
translation
so as long as you make sure that the
encoder is shared
they should learn a similar
representation for different languages
take this with a few other tricks um and
somehow this seems to magically
work and you can learn a model that
translates encodes sentences from
different languages
into a vector space which is shared and
then decodes them into
uh the different languages now i i want
to highlight that
all of these models rely on some
something that i call an anchor
which is some way to get some initial
mapping
usually what they do is they have word
embeddings
uh that are bilingual so at least we
know
for uh we have uh word vector
representations for
words in two different languages and a
mapping between them so we know which
uh how to map one to another and that
that is something that
um perhaps is not trivial to achieve
if you you're gonna want to translate
from whale sounds
to human language um
so this is this is a neural approach uh
it turns out that you can go back to the
old style
uh statistical machine translation
models so that i
showed in the beginning of this talk uh
with a lot of moving parts and
components and
it still works you can do unsupervised
machine translation and even
sometimes better than the neural network
approach uh but again there is an anchor
of these
bilingual word representation uh
so how well does this work in practice
here is the
table of results on machine translation
quality
these are called blue scores the higher
is better here
at the bottom you see a couple of
supervised approaches so this is
you are given translations and at the
training time
uh we can we can focus on this english
german pair
you get up to 35 uh and the unsupervised
results gets to
22. so is it is it good or bad
as a comparison you can see here this 20
this used to be the
state-of-the-art supervisor approach in
2014.
so by now you can
learn an unsupervised translation model
which is as good as the
best supervised model from a few years
ago
i think it's quite impressive okay
last topic for today
is artificial agent communication
so this is again a field with the long
history the question here is how to
build artificial agents that can
communicate
about some goal and if they do
communicate what are the properties of
their
the the the communication protocol that
they end up
learning and so we don't tell them uh
what is the protocol but we ask them to
develop some sort of communication
uh to give proper credit this product
draws very heavily on this very nice
overview paper by
zorido and perroni so i encourage you to
go look at that
uh so here are some example problems in
emerging communication and artificial
agents
this let's start with this we have two
agents a sender and a receiver
they get an input representation they
get some vector
and they need to transmit a message
in discrete symbols about this so this
message
z-a-b and then the receiver needs to
predict
the representation so this is a very
simple simulated problem that
was considered many years ago now things
become a little more complicated
as the years pass by so here we have two
agents
uh with some utilities regarding an
object
um and certain quantities to the object
and the
two agents need to negotiate uh between
them about how to use how to divide the
quantities of these objects and they do
so via again some symbolic
language some symbols that they exchange
you can also look at agents in a
simulated uh
problem so here they uh there are a
couple of
five agents that are in the maze and
they need to find
um an apple and they have certain goals
and they can communicate about these
um all the way up to more realistic
scenarios so perhaps we have agents in
real
um or in diagrams of
in 3d 3d environments
and they need to navigate and achieve
some sort of
goal but they do so by communicating
in the symbolic language okay
so the main components in those ai
agents these days
uh are three there's usually a visual
processing
component which is a deep convolutional
neural network
takes an input image and generates some
representation
there's a simple generation component
that that takes some
um uh representation
uh and generates the symbols that will
describe it
and there's an an understanding
component takes the symbol
and generator representation so you can
take those different components
and kind of build an agent that can
process images generate symbols and
understand
symbols that are transmitted to it by
another agent
um some of the challenges in this are
in understanding this language that
emerges are how to even segment
the messages what are the units what are
the words sentence the characters and so
on
what do the units mean what did they
refer to in the real world
are they consistent internally
i like this quote from this paper
saying that this enterprise is like
linguistic fieldwork except
that we're dealing with an alien race
with no guarantees that any universals
of human communication will apply
um so i also like this because maybe
that tells us that
some of the techniques here can can be
applied to
not alien races but animal animal
species
in terms of analyzing this emergent
communication there's a lot of open
questions of compositionality the main
question is
is this agent can this agent express
novel concept beyond what
it has seen but compose them from either
parts which is also
i think an important language for any
language
uh any language research
okay i think that's all i had uh so uh
thank you if there are any questions
i'm not sure we have much time but uh we
can try
so you have a whole bunch of questions
in the in the chat
chat okay let me go there oh there's
also some questions in the q a but i
think more in the chat
i think all the way to 1207.
yep uh so there's a question from luigi
have you tried to apply this work to
explore how metaphors and rhetoric
figures are learned
it would be interesting to explore
there's a gradient of meaning
that then is categorized in another
category rather than an expressed one
there's a clarification i mean to
explore which layer would capture more
information about the literal meaning of
the sentence
which one would categorize them in the
figurative meaning yes
uh this is a very good question i
personally have not
dealt with that um there is not so much
work on
metaphors and rhetoric and um in nlp
although there is a bit and i think
there's a workshop on
figurative language in nlp that has
started
in the first in the last couple of years
so this is maybe a bit premature
but hopefully there will be more uh
there's a there was a question from
shafi but i think chavez says i answered
it
so i could um skip that
and then q a you have a few also yeah
okay
q a 1202
um there was a question by maximilian
that
seems to have been answered so i'll skip
that then there's a question from john
payne
do you think the voider and title
approach could be important for
practical training since it could
indicate which layers are doing better
higher ratio of accuracy to complication
of encoding
yes um that's a very good idea so
this void i'm tied about the approach
was to
not only say the quality of the
representation based on the classifier
but also
tell us something about the complexity
um and yes in fact that
tells us something about how difficult
it was to extract in
the information from the encoding
uh so if you know that you could perhaps
improve training
the question is how in general uh
many of the insights that we get are
super interesting but not always very
actionable so i think this is still a
challenge
for the community there's a question
from peter
about do the hierarchy results still
hold when trained on non-european
languages
um yes this is a good question
and okay so first let me say there's
unfortunately not a lot of work on
non-european languages
not even on non-english languages so
most of the workers
on english although i've shown results
on other languages in the ones i showed
i only
shown european although they were from
somewhat very different groups
so recall that there was czech in there
uh there's also
we've also experimented with chinese and
did see
quite similar results in terms of the of
the hierarchy to the extent that some of
these
aspects exist or don't exist
so my answer would be kind of but
more work is needed to answer
okay any more questions um
i guess there was there's another
question in the chat
from aza raskin thoughts on if or
how emergent communication and ai agents
be constrained in such a way so that it
better approximates
specific animal vocalization
i think that would be a question more
for the experts on animal vocalizations
than
to me so i i will refrain but if you
have any thoughts
i'm happy to hear yes
yeah i have a question this unsupervised
maybe to you it may be to michael but
this unsupervised way of uh
training these uh different languages in
order to do language to language
translation
how similar should these language be in
order to generate this similar type of
embedding
yeah and the assumption here is that
they generate that they're
transformed into similar type of
embedding right
right unsupervised first of all are they
enforced
are there some supervised examples that
enforce these embeddings to be the same
under the supervised examples
or is it totally unsupervised but then
there must be some assumption that the
these embeddings are similar and i okay
if the languages are relatively similar
but i wonder if they're very very
different differently structured
languages if this would still hold
yeah this i think this is a very good
point so you can see here in the table
the languages
that people usually experiment with are
french english
and german english so these are pretty
similar
um you know at least they have the same
writing systems and some of the
grammatical structure is also the same
and if i go back to the how this is done
you know they have all these that all
sort of complicated
topologies of networks and objective
functions and so on but
there is this anchor of bilingual world
embedding so that the building blocks
um are mapped in a pre in a
pre-processing step
so so first we assume that we have word
embeddings from two different languages
which are aligned
in in vector space so how do you get
those
um that's a that's another question and
there are almost
unsupervised ways to get those you could
train them separately
train those water embeddings separately
on two different languages and then
align them um with the alignment
yeah so so what ends up happening if you
if you look into the details and i hope
that i'm faithful to the work
uh but what what ends up happening is
that eventually they have some very very
small
seed uh lexicon uh of
words that they manually line
and this c laksa contracts for example
could be just digits so in some cases
you just see digits because
digits are spelled the same in
in the different languages that they've
experiments
experimented with but it is a it is a
limitation there's
still some human human involvement on
a supervised step so to speak uh
small but still it's there
i guess my question is if if i remember
correctly
they had a follow-up paper where they
didn't do any any landmarks
uh uh any corresponding words so it was
really uh unsupervised and
from what i i also remember and again
take it with a grain of salt
first i'm not an expert in nlp and
second i
uh i might be distorting the details of
the paper
so it's better to look it up but from
what i remember the claim was also that
the more languages you add the better so
if you have if you try to align
simultaneously
multiple languages then uh uh then it
helps
so i i think so so i that thanks for
thanks for this uh clarification so
maybe i have a
gap in my immune knowledge here
so um i was gonna ask more questions but
i think we're way over a schedule so
let's thank you natan again thank you